well esther you know
that i love all things that are good and
holy
but if he
doesn't let go of my grandniece grace
i'm gonna cut the devil's dick off and
shove it in his hands
[Music]
with my prayers i know you will
father please hear our prayer for the
poor thank you father yes we beseech you
for the disenfranchised the less
fortunate
and those that suffer
show us your will
so we can continue to do your work yeah
listen carefully to my instructions
hallelujah
i want you to sell everything you own
and immediately begin service to the
poor
[Music]
just want to clarify um
to everything
yes
rid yourself of all earthly possessions
[Music]
oh
this house is on
oh
i see what they did there
hey i i just got a text from charles
y'all he got on the wrong bus he's on
the other side of town other side of
town but our concert is in an hour yeah
i know but but he wants us to warm up
and rehearse praise to the lord charles
said that in text okay okay well if
that's what charles said yeah that's
okay we got this we can do what we can
do to do this come
8 we on up to the lord we give praise up
to the lord we sing merely up to the
lord
give thanks up to the lord
we lift up to the lord we give praise up
to the lord we sing merrily up to the
lord
give face up to the lord
i think you're going from your note
you're going higher than your note
pretty sure this is my note in fact i'm
positive this is my note because this is
my note pretty sure this is my note
could have sworn this was your note that
has never been my note well we can't
have the same note so one of us is wrong
why don't you worry about your note i'll
take care of my own nose but it's a
really really really bad note
you are not taught i never said that i
was charles well you acting like you
thank you charles look i know that i'm
not charles you can't say that again
well you're both off your notes and it's
messing with the rest of our notes
speak for yourself
i wasn't trying to single you out you
said everyone was off that note not
everything is about you gina
kiss my black ass
[Music]
[Music]
happy sunday esther happy sunday
giardino
how was your week oh the lord is with me
mm-hmm but the devil
he got his hands on my grandniece grace
oh no mm-hmm they're smoking the reefer
doing the hanky-panky with boys
esther you know
that i love all things that are good and
holy
but if he
doesn't let go of my grandness grace
i'm gonna cut the devil's dick off and
shove it in his ass
[Music]
with my prayers i know you will joe gina
i know you will
how was your weak girl oh you know me
i'm blessed and thankful for every day
mm-hmm all right but you know my
grandson jason got himself wrapped up in
the leathery claws of satan not jason he
got himself arrested for the spray
painting and the vandalism oh lord and i
tell you i never
raised my hand in anger but if he don't
let jason go i'm gonna punch that [ __ ]
satan in the nuts so hard it wiped the
dick licking smirk off his horned ass
face
[Music]
with my prayers amen i know you will
esther i know you will but esther i
gotta tear you something nice now
let it out you know esther that i have
found serenity in the glory of heaven
yes but my daughter's husband bernard
has got himself wedged between the cleft
hooves and lucifer herself
she opened up her laptop computer right
and found the pornography of women not
the pornography of absolutely the
pornography of women not on a laptop
computer
i am a pacifist under god's request but
if he don't let go of bernard i'm gonna
sneak up on that [ __ ] ass lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time
and then i'm gonna sit on that
motherfucker's head and i'm gonna spread
my booty cheeks on that pig's face
and i'm gonna just pucker up my stank
hole
and just tubes tubes tubes scoops
[ __ ] got a brown dot on his nose that i
can use for target practice
with your prayers of course of course oh
georgina georgina georgina
oh i got nothing but face and god in
heaven above but i tell you my son's
wife crystal she got herself wrapped up
in the fiery wings of mephistopheles
herself here we go you know she got
caught using profanity with her own
children what at the dinner table oh
lord chad aren't you
a dream about a mountain oh i have
nothing but love for every creature on
this planet but if he don't let my
darling crystal go i'm gonna flirt with
the devil oh oh
show him a little bit of shoulder how
you doing he's gonna start looking away
i'm gonna start twerking start twerking
he's gonna be like where he's gonna be
he's gonna be drawn in seduce that
little [ __ ] you can one of these
batting my eyelashes at him then when he
least expects it and i got his trust
that's when i'm gonna ride that [ __ ]
i'm gonna give him the night of his life
and now you ain't never gonna forget you
don't give em this way i'm gonna give
him that way and then right when he
about to climax that's when i'm gonna
clinch up my [ __ ] on that
motherfucker's red dick and i'm gonna
snack that [ __ ] [ __ ] off with a divine
kegel well you gotta snap that little
[ __ ]
with your prayers with your hands of
course with the prayers yeah but that's
right girl yeah you go get them yes [ __ ]
satan [ __ ] him [ __ ] him indeed
[Music]
what's happening
georgina isn't here
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
oh give me some of that
i want a piece of him yeah
what's going on this feels good why
would you do this to me oh you've seen
him a second [ __ ]
i'm waiting oh you're a gum here i come
here
oh
my god
please please get these crazy [ __ ]
off of me
jesus christ my personal lord and savior
i swear
[Music]
come now mary magdalene
stand and be forgiven for your sins
but jesus
how can i be forgiven
i'm a prostitute no child
you were a prostitute
that life is behind you now
mary magdalene
where are you at [ __ ] oh no jesus
i think it's my pimp i think he found me
oh there you are man it took me forever
to find your ass i'll be looking all
over for you you know how many [ __ ]
named mary there i've been here now get
your wheels in that caravan no
no i'm not going with you gala leroy i'm
gonna stay here with jesus
what the flip is this you're washing
this feet maybe what i taught you that i
rescued you from the fishing village i
cleaned you up and got you out to work
and now that's how you repay me you go
get yourself another pimp hell no
brother she's mine i don't think you
understand
she's not going with you well i can't
afford to lose i already lost three
[ __ ] to leprosy all right all i got
left is mary a [ __ ] and two blind
chicks who
actually you know they get requested a
lot don't ask me how that works get out
of here i'm not going with you galileo
i'm staying here with jesus and i'm
warning you jesus has like 12 followers
tell them oh 12.
okay all right so this [ __ ] a
serious pimp no my friend you're
confused it's 12 men uh wha are you a
gay pimp i'm not a pimp i'm a carpenter
carpenter
then why does your house look like
i've been busy with non-carpentry work
okay that's it [ __ ] packing get in the
caravan and make me some money no and i
don't have any stuff to pack jesus says
we don't need things what the is this
all about money hell yeah it's all about
money brother
i have a saying oh it goes like this
you're gonna love this shut up it's
easier for a camel to pass through the
eye of a needle than for a rich man to
enter the kingdom of god
oh yeah well i got a saying too
it's easy you know why don't you pass
your own
pass your ass through the needle man
[ __ ] you man come on
girl stairs
[Music]
i slapped you and you want me to hit you
on the other cheek that ain't gangsta
this is crazy you can have them i'm done
wait friend
[Music]
so you know that there are no hard
feelings
would you care to join us for dinner
what y'all have
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm joseph carmichael
otis
is
was my father
but we are not here today to mourn his
death
but to celebrate his life
we knew otis as a teacher
a community leader
a role model a husband
and a father
now i thought it would be nice to share
something about him you all may not have
known
when my father was younger he was an
actor in hollywood
going through my dad's things i found
this reel
of his work as an actor
i haven't seen it yet but i thought it
would be fun to watch
here with all of you today
[Music]
where are my pies
ribbles
where are the pies i put on my
windowsill
why i don't know mr brother why would
anyone want to steal one of your
delicious blueberry pie
hey see to it you shine those shoes up
nice boy
yes sir
you best be believing i will
i'll shine your shoes blacker than my
mama's booty
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
in 1964
my father marched with martin luther
king jr and jerebel fonte along with
other renowned civil rights league
[Music]